is a big fan of paris's electric
scooters he says he hires one most days
to get around the city
these scooters are really useful because
Paris is so busy especially in rush hour
it's impossible to move around so thanks
to these we can use the cycle Lanes it's
much better than a car
e-scooters were introduced in France in
2018 since then they've become part of
the landscape in most cities but some
people say they're a nuisance cluttering
Pavements and endangering pedestrians
now the French government's launched a
new plan to regulate them Riders will
have to be at least 14 years old and
they'll be tougher penalties for misuse
two people on an e-scooter is forbidden
today but the fine is only 35 Euros so
it'll be raised to 135 Euros the
messages that dangerous Behavior will be
penalized dedicated parking zones and
lower speed limits are already in place
while the French government is stepping
up its regulation of electric scooters
here in Paris the city hall is asking
people to vote on whether or not to ban
them
the three companies that provide paris's
e-scooters say a ban would make no sense
in a city that's often led the way in
promoting low-carbon alternatives to
cars and motorbikes we very hope indeed
that the vote will be positive and that
perishing's people will continue to
welcome scooters in a safe and
sustainable way in the city
opinion on the streets though is divided
I can see they offer an alternative form
of Transport but at the same time they
can be dangerous for pedestrians the
elderly
I think they've not been around long
enough to just scrap them we need more
research on things like dangers
mortality and perhaps we need better
infrastructure for them because the
folks taking place in polling stations
rather than online it's expected to be
dominated by older people who are more
likely to favor a ban once the results
are in it'll be up to paris's Mayor to
make the final decision on whether it's
really the end of the road for
e-scooters in the city Natasha Butler Al
Jazeera Paris